[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قال الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ان الاجراءات الامنيه التي
اتخذتها بلاده على الحدود مع قطاع غزه لا
تهدف الى الاساءه للفلسطينيين وقال بيان
اصدرته الرئاسه المصر ان الرئيس السيسي
اكد ان الاجراءات التي تتخذها مصر من اجل
تامين حدودها الشرقيه تتم بتنسيق كامل مع
السلطه الفلسطينيه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما حقيقه دور السلطه الفلسطينيه
فيما يتعرض له قطاع غزه من
حصار وما هي الاسباب التي تمنع السلطه من
تولي دورها في اداره المعابر مع
مصر
[موسيقى]
لم يكن بيان الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي عن
وجود تنسيق بين مصر والسلطه الفلسطينيه
بشان الاجراءات الامنيه على الحدود مع
قطاع غزه مفاجئا فالرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس كان قد اعلن في مقابله تلفزيونيه ان
تدمير الانفاق كان مطلبا قدمه للنظام في
مصر كما اوضح ان ردم هذه الانفاق في رفح
بمياه البحر كما تفعل السلطات المصريه
اليوم كان واحدا من مقترحات قبل عام
تقريبا تصريح الرئيس المصري جاء ليصب
الزيت على نار العلاقه بين السلطه وحماس
ويثير تساؤلات عن الاسباب التي تمنع تفعيل
اتفاق المصالحه بين الجانبين خاصه ما تعلق
منه بازمه المعابر الحدوديه تقرير زياد
بركات يلقي رئيسها كلمه في الامم المتحده
فتنشغل وزيره التضامن الاجتماعي المصريه
بما يناقض مفهوم التضامن بما هو شخصي
ونرجسي طفولي تلتقط سيلفي لنفسها وتلك هي
السياسه في حقبه الرجل فالامر يعني نقيضه
وبذلك يفاخر يلتقي هنا في نيويورك برئيس
السلطه الفلسطينيه فيخرج الاثنان بخلاصه
واحده وهي ان اغراق انفاق غزه والتضييق
على اهلها وتدمير تربتها الزراعيه وتلويث
مياهها الجوفيه لا يهدف للاساءه الى
الفلسطينيين بل هو لحمايه الحدود لا من
اسرائيل بل من سكان القطاع ويتم ذلك وفقا
للسيسي بالتنسيق الكامل مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه عباس نفسه لا ينفي بل يؤكد وم
دعاه فخره ان الفكره نفسها فكرته من
الاساس نحن نعتبر ان الانفاق غير شرعيه ا
يعني دخل غير شرعي ا وكنت استغرب يعني
اتكلم كثيرا وفي كل مناسبه يا اخوان هذا
يجب ان يقفل وكنت اجيب مشاريع خرايط مره
نقول نحط مي نردم بالمي مره ب ماذا يعني
الامن الوطني لعباس لا احد يعرف والرجل لا
يفصح تحاصر غزه ويقضي اطفالها اعيادهم بين
الخرائب فلا يوجه لهم رساله تضامن واحده
يقتل احد وزرائه في اشتباك مع الجنود
الاسرائيليين فيقول مقربون منه انه اوقف
التنسيق الامني ردا على ذلك ليتكشف الامر
على فجيعه استمراره يقتحم متطرفون يهود
المسجد الاقصى فلا يعلن حاله التاهب في
صفوف قواته الامنيه بل يفعل الاسوا يترك
هذه القوات لتبر مواطنيه ضربا وهم من
خرجوا نصره للاقصى ينتهي به الامر لاعلان
شراكته في حصار شعبه او ما يفترض ان
يكون هنا بعض مما تركه اغراق الانفاق وتلك
لم تكن لتهريب المخدرات على ما يعلم عب
بل حاجيات الغزيين الاساسيه من مواد
غذائيه وطبيه ومواد ضروريه لاعاده الاعمار
بمعناه البدائي وكان مطلب الفلسطينيين
هناك فتح المعابر مع مصر لانهاء الحصار من
جذوره وتفكيك ما يقول كثيرون انه اقتصاد
قام على الانفاق وانتج طبقته والمستفيدين
منه والمتضررين منه ايضا لكنه يظل ضروريا
لان بدائله ان يموت نحو مليون فلسطيني
خنقا ما بين حدود مغلقه مع الجاره الكبرى
وتضييق اسرائيلي يحصي على الغزيين انفاسهم
ويدفعهم الى الموت جوعا او التوسل
للاسرائيليين والرضوخ لشروطه عباس كان
شريكا كما قال بنفسه اما الغزيون فرفضوا
ويرفضون ما يراد ان يكون
قدرهم نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من رام
الله الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عبد المجيد
سويلم ومن نابلس الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
عبد الستار قاسم سيد سويلم حديث الرئيس
السيسي عن تنسيق كامل مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه في اجراءاته
الاخيره في عن غزه كيف يمكن ان
يفهم والله انا بالنسبه لي يفهم بشكل
طبيعي بمعنى هذه ليست احجيه سياسيه مساله
معروفه مصر لها وجهه نظر واضحه صريحه
ومحدده بان المشكله لا تكمن مع اهل غزه
المشكله تكمن مع حركه حماس هلا في ناس
بهذا العالم العربي لا يريدون ان يفهموا
ان المشكله مع حركه حماس هذا شانهم
المشكله يا سيدي مع حركه حماس حركه حماس
هي امتداد للاخوان المسلمين الاخوان
المسلمين بالنسبه للنظام المصري هو تنظيم
ارهابي بغض النظر عن راينا في صحه او عدم
صحه ذلك بالتالي المساله لها علاقه بالامن
القومي المصري الى ان تحل هذه المساله
مساله كيف يمكن ان يطمئن النظام الى
الشريك الموجود في قطاع غزه لا اعتقد بان
دوله في هذا العالم تقبل بان يكون الشريك
المقابل لها في المنطقه المحدده وفي مثل
هذه الحاله نحن نتحدث عن غزه لا يمكن ان
نيكون خصما وعدوا و وفي نفس الوقت ان تكون
العلاقه طبيعيه المساله اذا هي تكمن في
تحكم قطاع تحكم حماس بقطاع غزه بكل بساطه
المصريون يقولون عندما تتفقون كفلسطينيين
على السلطه الشرعيه استطيع التعامل معها
لانه لا يمكن ان تعقل لا يمكن ان يعقل ان
دوله مصريه عمرها 7000 سنه ستقيم علاقه مع
فصيل سياسي هذا هذا شيء خارج عن المالوف ش
عن الطبيعي عن الذي نعرفه يعني في القانون
الدولي شيء غير ممكن مستحيل من الناحيه
القانونيه من ناحيه سياده الدوله من ناحيه
طبيعه علاقه الدوله بالشعب الفلسطيني
وبالقضية حماس بان المشكله تكمن في هذه
النقطه بالذات وانه لا لا بديل عن وجود
سلطه شرعيه معترف بها في القانون الدولي
تكون حاكمه لقطاع غزه او على الاقل تتسلم
المعابر تتسلم ال القضايا الرئيسيه التي
تعطي الشكل الرئيسي ل للمساله القانونيه
الى ان يتم ذلك من يعتقد بان المصريين
سيفتحون ل لحركه حماس المجال لكي تنفصل عن
الجسم الوطني في الوقت الذين الذي يعرفون
فيه ويتاكد ويدركون ولديهم الوثائق ولديهم
الوقائع عن مشكلات كبيره بعلاقه حركه حماس
بالاخوان وعلاقه على على ذكر حماس على ذكر
حماس والاخوان سيد سويلم على ذكر على ذكر
على ذكر الاخوان بعد اذنك على ذكر الاخوان
وحماس
السلطه الحكم في مصر يعتبر حركه الاخوان
في مصر حركه ارهابيه ولكنه لا يصنف حماس
بهذا
الشكل رسميا لكن اشرت الى نقطه اشرت الى
انا لم اقل انه يصنف حماد قلت يعتبر حركه
الاخوان نعم اشرت الى نقطه مهمه اريد ان
نقلها للسيد عبد الستار قاسم اشرت الى ان
البعض قد يفهم وجهه النظر هذه المصريه
والبعض الاخر لا يريد ان يفهمه وهو حر في
ذلك انا اريد ان افهم الى اي مدى الجانب
الفلسطيني او الشعب الفلسطيني وهو المهم
في هذه المعادله قادر على استيعاب وجهه
النظر التي كان يشرحها الان سيد سويلم
بخذ بعين الاعتبار المصالح المصريه
والنظره المصريه الى قطاع
غزه هو من الصعب جدا على الشعب الفلسطيني
ان يستوعب وجهه النظر المصريه لان مصر حتى
الان لم تقدم اي ادله وبينات قاطعه مانعه
بان حركه حماس تشجع الارهابيين في سيناء
وتعر ض الامن القومي المصري للخطر مصر لم
تقدم حتى الان اي بينات او اي دليل من اجل
ادانه حركه حماس هناك انطباعات يتحدث عنها
الاعلام المصري الذي لا يكل ولا يمل في
كيل الشتائم للشعب الفلسطيني نعم هم
يتحدثون عن انطباعات الانطباعات لا ترتقي
الى مستوى الدليل والبرهان واذا كان في
هناك خطر على الامن القومي المصري فالسيسي
نفسه هو الاساس في هذا الخطر لما يقوم به
من اجراءات داخل مصر وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بحفلات الاعدام الجماعيه او احكام الاعدام
الجماعيه التي يتخذها في في المحاكم
المصريه هذا شيء يثير الكراهيه والبغضاء
والاحقاد داخل المجتمع
المصري المج هذا التمزيق يمكن ان يكون
نبقى حتى نبقى في الموضوع منظورا اليه بين
الجانب الفلسطيني والجانب المصري الشان
المصري الداخلي هذه قضيه اخرى قد قد نعود
اليها في في مناسبات اخرى ولكن هل هل
يوجد اذا اخذنا دور السلطه الفلسطينيه هل
دور السلطه الفلسطينيه
بتقديرك يمكن فهمه في هذه العلاقه مع
الحكومه المصريه حول موضوع
غزه شوف الكريم استاذ محمد المنطقه الدول
العربيه بما فيها السلطه الفلسطينيه هي
تقف معاديه للمقاومه سواء المقاومه في
لبنان او في فلسطين وكلهم يجتمعون ويفكرون
معا ويتخذون اجراءات معا من اجل القضاء
على المقاومه هو اللي بيعترف باسرائيل
واللي بيطبع مع اسرائيل وينسق امنيا مع
اسرائيل ماذا يريد يريد من كل الاخرين ان
يسيروا في نفس الاتجاه الذي يسير هو فيه
حتى لا يكون هو المدان الوحيد في التاريخ
وانما يريد ان يداني الجميع وبالتالي كل
هذه الدول تتكالب
وتتعاون وتعمل معا من اجل القضاء على
المقاومه الان في غزه في مقاومه وهذه
المقاومه صمدت على مدى ثلاث حروب وافشل
حروب اسرائيل 2014 2012 2008 2009 وهي
قادره وتتقدم عسكريا باستمرار وقدراتها
التقنيه ايضا تتطور الان لماذا الحصار من
اجل خنق غزه والغريب انه السيسي عندما
يتحدث يقول انه لا تهدف هذه الامور الى
الاساءه للشعب الفلسطيني ولا هو تسيء لمين
هذه الاجراءات تسيء لناس على المريخ او في
الزهره هي تسيء للشعب الفلسطيني وبالتالي
اذا لم يكن هذا هدفه فهذا هو الواقع الذي
يعيشه اهل غزه وهم يعانون امر المعاناه
بسبب الاجراءات المصريه وطبعا الحصار هو
ليس من مصر فقط وانما من كل دول العالم
لكن مصر هي التي تشدد في الحصار ول و ولكن
بالنسبه بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه
بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه تحديدا نعم
بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه تحديدا سيد عبد
المجيد
سويلم ان ان تتفهم السلطه الفلسطينيه
الاعتبارات الامنيه المصريه وتراعي جار
باهميه مصر هذا امر مفهوم ولكن لماذا تمضي
الى اكثر من ذلك وتبدي ليس فقط تفهم
للاعتبارات الامنيه المصريه وانما تبدي
حماسه لها و تبدو احيانا اقصى منها في
الحديث عن وجاهه ما اتخذته مصر من اجراءات
لماذا الى هذا
الحد يعني هذا يعود
لاعتبارات كثيره بس اهم هذه الاعتبارات هو
الموقف الوطني يا سيدي السلطه الفلسطينيه
وانا بعتقد غالبيه الشعب الفلسطيني
يعتبرون ان النظام القائم في مصر هو نظام
وطني ونظام وطني محترم وهو لم يقم باي
اساءه لا لحركه حماس ولا لغير حركه حماس
هذا المساله بكل بساطه ان هذه الحركه
تتحكم بقطاع غزه بطريقه غير شرعيه قامت
بانقلاب استباحت به الدم وقتلت الناس
بالشوارع وسحلت هذه م يعني وقائع لديكم
بال الارشيف تستطيعون الاطلاع عليها هذه
المساله منذ ثمان سنوات ونحن نحاول ان
نتحرك مع حركه حماس باتجاه الوصول الى
قواسم مشتركه السلطه الفلسطينيه يا سيدي
الفاضل بلغه الارقام وعلم الاحصاء الذي لا
يكذب وممكن ان يخدع لكن لا يكذب احنا بلغه
الارقام وبلغه الاحصاء 45 46 احيانا 48
اقل معدل كان 42% من موازنه السلطه يذهب
لاهلنا في قطاع غزه من نصب دكتور عبد
الستار قاسم يعني كيف نصب نفسه ليتحدث
باسم الشعب في غزه من قال من الذي يقول
بان السلطه
الفلس اسمحلي سيد سويلم لا لا انت لا اسمح
لي فقط فقط للتوضيح فقط للتوضيح لا انت نص
بناك متحدثا باسم السلطه ولا السيد عبد
الستار قاسم نصبنا متحدثا باسم غزه نحن
اتينا بكم لانكم تعكس
اسي
احتراف كل واحد منكم يعبر عن مزاج معين
وبالتالي استضفنا لهذا السبب وبالتالي هو
ليس متحدثا لا باسم غزه ولا باسم ولا انت
متحدث باسم
غزه
السطه د لا نتحدث باسم احد ودعونا نعبر عن
الطيف الذي تفضلت بالاشاره اليه ليس عندي
مشكله على هذا على هناك نقطه مهمه اشرت
اليها سيد نريد ان نعود بعد الفاصل بعد
اذنك هو هو
حقيقه المعابر حقيقه المعابر يفترض ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه هي التي تسيطر على
المعابر بين غزه ومصر هذا هو ليس واقع
الحال وهذا ما يفترض ان يطبق بموجب اتفاق
المصالحه نريد ان نعرف بعد الفاصل ما الذي
حال دون ذلك لحد الان لنا وقفه بعد هذه
بعد هذا الفاصل في هذه المساله نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها دور السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه فيما يتعرض له قطاع
غزه من اجراءات مؤخرا السيد عبد الستار
قاسم هناك وجهه نظر تقول بان لو تولت
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مسؤوليه
المعابر لما وصلنا الى هذا المستوى من
الجدل مع مصر ولما وصلنا ربما الى هذه
الاجراءات التي
ربما تسيء للشعب الفلسطيني هل هل هناك
تقصير ما على هذا
المستوى لا يا اخي يعني لو كانت السلطه
الفلسطينيه هي على المعابر هي نفس النتيجه
لان المشكله ليست في المعابر المشكله في
وجود المقاومه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واسرائيل اسل لو كان اسمح لي لو كانت
السلطه الوطنيه لو كانت السلطه الوطنيه
على المعابر رسميا لن تسمح بوجود الانفاق
وبالتالي تنتفي ايه حجه يمكن ان تفهم على
انها اساءه لمن القومي المري هناك
فرق
ماه يا استذ محمد ما هي الانفاق هي شريان
الحياه
لغزه يعني حتى لو كانت السلطه يعني بدها
تدمر الانفاق نفس النتيجه والهدف في
النهايه هو الضغط على اهل غزه من اجل ان
يثوروا على الوضع القائم الان في غزه اي
الاطاحه بالمقاومه او على الاقل تحجيمها
او تجريدها من السلاح الى اخره يعني احنا
نفس النتيجه لانه المساله تتعلق بالمقاومه
وليس بالمعابر دول المنطقه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل والى اخر لا
يريدون بقاء المقاومه وبالتالي يحاربونها
بكافه الاشكال ثم لو كانت السلطه
الفلسطينيه ايضا على المعابر هي من
الناحيه الامنيه غير مؤتمنه السلطه
الفلسطينيه تعرض امن الشعب الفلسطيني
للخطر هذا وارد في الضفه الغربيه و يمكن
ان يرد ايضا في قطاع غزه فيما لو كانت
السلطه الفلسطينيه على المعابر لماذا لان
التعاون الامني ما بين اسرائيل والسلطه
قائم والتعاون الامني ما بين مصر واسرائيل
ايضا قائم ولكن ولكن ولكن في هذه الحاله
سيد عبد الر قاسم في هذه الحاله في هذه
الحاله لماذا لا نقول يعني في هذه الحاله
لماذا لا نقول بان وجود السلطه على هذه
المعابر وهذا التنسيق الامني وهذا التنسيق
مع مصر سيوفر بيئه امنه للفلسطينيين حتى
يعيشوا بامان في حين يرى البعض الاخر بان
حركه حماس هي التي ربما تجلب المصائب
للفلسطينيين في في غزه من خلال هذه
المقاومه التي تشير اليه اذا يتوقف الامر
من اي منظار
ننظر ما هو انت اللي بتفضل فيه اللي بتفضل
فيه الان نعم هم يريدون الوصول الى هذه
النتيجه انه حماس هي الماساه المقاومه هي
الماساه ويجب ان نواجهها هذا ما يريده ما
يريدونه وقد وكم من مره حاولوا من اجل
تحريض الناس في قطاع غزه من اجل ان يقوموا
ضد المقاومه الفلسطينيه وليس ضد حركه حماس
بالتحديد فقط وانما ستكون في حركه الجهاد
مشموله معهم ايضا فبالتالي في مشكله امنيه
خطيره يا استاذ نحن معرضين امنيا في خطر
علينا من الداخل ومن الخارج اسرائيل ولكن
في النهايه ما الذي منع ما الذي منع الاال
نعم ما الذي منع السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه سيد سويلم من ان تتولى امن
المعابر هل هي كما يقول السيد عبد الستار
قاسم تحاول ان يصل التبرم والضجر من اهالي
غزه الى درجه الانفجار والتمرد على حماس
هل هذا هو الهدف
فعلا يعني ساجيب على هذا السؤال اذا
اعطيتني فرصه لاعلق قليلا على ما سبق انا
اقترح على حركه حماس وعلى الدكتور عبد
الستار قا
وعلى كل اجواء حركه حماس الاقليميه ان
تختبر المصريين بمعنى ان تسلم المعابر
للسلطه الفلسطينيه لترى في فيما اذا كانت
مصر جاده ام غير جاده في مساله فتح المعبر
واعطاء كل التسهيلات باعتبار ان السلطه
المقابله هي سلطه شرعيه معترف بها مؤتمن
من قبل المصريين ولا تشكل خطرا على خاصرته
انا يعني فقط ادعو الى اختبار المصريين
حتى نتاكد قبل ان ندعي وقبل ان نحاول
تصوير الواقع على ما هو مغاير تماما لما
تتفضلون به من من وجهه نظر انا اقول
اختبروا المصريين واختبروا الرئيس عباس
واختبروا فتح واختبروا السلطه الفلسطينيه
فيما اذا كان هناك فعلا نيه صادقه ام لا
فيما يخص يعني ايه معبر رفح وما يخص
العلاقه ما بين يعني مصر وقطاع غزه هذا
اولا وثانيا الذي منع يا سيدي بكل بساطه
انا اقول لك بكل يعني اذا كان اذا كان
هناك في فعلا قيمه البحث عن الحقيقه وليس
قيمه البحث عن الايديولوجيات يا سيدي
المعابر اتفق في الشاطئ انه المفترض انه
تتسلمها قوات الامن الرئاسه واتفق على انه
الوزراء يذهبون الى قطاع غزه من اجل
ممارسه صلاحياتهم جزء منهم ضرب بالبيض
وجزء منهم ضرب
ثم هجمت البنوك قبل ان تصل قبل ان يصل
الوفد للمره الاولى الى قطاع غزه كانت
قوات امن حماس تحرض الناس على ضرب الوزراء
وعلى الاساءه لهم ومنع الناس من الاجتماع
بهم وحشرهم في الفندق يا اخوان هذه ليست
توقعات هذه ليست اراء سياسيه يا اخوان
لديكم في الجزيره وثائق حول الموضوع مصوره
ارجوكم لمره واحده ان نكون ان نحاول ان
نكون حياديين فيذا الموضوع من الذي منع
الوزراء من ممارسه
حقهم في ان يمارسوا سلطتهم على وزاراتهم
لماذا تمنع حركه حماس ما الذي يضير حركه
حماس ان تتسلم قوات الرئاسه او قوات الامن
الوطني او الشرطه الفلسطينيه الشرعيه
التابعه للسلطه الوطنيه الشرعيه المعابر
ما الذي يضر حركه حماس حركه حماس يا سيدي
تبحث عن وسائل لاستمرار سيطرتها وتحكمها
بقطاع غزه وا واستغلال واستثمار عذابات
شعبنا من اجل مشروعها مشروعها الخاص الذي
ليس له علاقه من قريب او من بعيد لا
بفلسطين ولا بالمقاومه هو مشروع كيفيه
السيطره من قبل حركه حماس على قطاع غزه
حركه حماس ذهبت عند الاسرائيليين بساطه
قطريه وتركيه على ذكر الوساطه ط دعني فاكر
هذه النقطه ذهبت هناك لتبيع لا اسمح لي
فقط يعني
طالح انه انهي الفكره فقط انهي الفكره
طالما ان اتفاق
المصالحه تم و حسم موضوع المعابر على ان
يعود الى السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه مشروع المصالحه متعثر في اكثر
من من نقطه متعثر في الحكومه متعثر في في
كثير من في الرواتب متعثر ومتعثر ايضا في
في المعابر اذا القضيه اعمق من مجرد
المعابر هل تعتقد فعلا انه حماس وحدها
تتحمل لا طبعا انا لم اقل انه المعابر هي
المشكله الوحيده لكن يا سيدي الذي نراه هو
انهم بانهم في كل مره نذهب باتجاه اتفاق
يختلقون لنا مشكله كبيره ومشكله جديده وا
استدراكات جديده وتوقعات جديده وا يعني
متطلبات جديده يا سيدي الفاضل حماس برعايه
قطريه وتركيه ذهبت لكي تبيع مشروع
المقاومه ل 15 سنه مقابل انهم يفتحوا لهم
يعني هذه السفينه بال بال البحر اسرائيل
هي التي رفضت عن اي مقاومه نتحدث يعني
دعونا لا لا لا يعني نمعن في في خداع
الشعب الفلسطيني
ايها شهداء اكثر من حركه فتح اشرت الى
اشرت الى نقطه مهمه جدا اريد ان اسال عنها
سيد عبد الستار قاسم في نهايه البرنامج
وهو موضوع اختبار اختبار السلطه واختبار
مصر لماذا بتقديرك لا تسعى حماس الى هذا
الاختبار تسلم المعابر للسلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه
وهنا يمتحن الجميع برايك ما
العائق يا استاذ محمد يعني احنا هل ينقصنا
تجارب وهل ينقصنا خبره نحن جربنا يعني
مثلا مصر هي التي فقدت قطاع غزه وهي التي
تقيم علاقات مع اسرائيل طيب اين البعد
الاخلاقي في هذا الكلام اولا يجب على مصر
ان تحرر قطاع غزه ثم تسلمه للشعب
الفلسطيني اما الدير ظاهرها للشعب
الفلسطيني وهي التي خسرت الحرب عام 1967
هذا عمل لا اخلاقي وغير مقبول الشيء
الثاني بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه طيب
ماحنا بخبرها وهينا عايشين معها في الضفه
الغربيه ونرى اعمالها السيئه
للغايه السلطه الفلسطينيه فاشله في كل
المعايير واذا كنا نتحدث عن دول فاشله نحن
يجب ان نتحدث حدث عن سلطه فاشله نشرت
الفساد في كل مكان اثرت سلبيا على النسيج
الاجتماعي للشعب الفلسطيني شكرا جزي ش
وعلى النسيج الاخلاقي وايضا اثرت سلبيا
على الوضع الاقتصادي الى اخره الى اخره
شكتي يعني شو بدي اجرب شكرا واهم شيء في
كل الموضوع انه نحن بنشتغل نحن بنشتغل
وكلاء للاحتلال يا خيي على كل شكرا جزيلا
لك سيد عبد الستار قاسم الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي الفلسطيني من نابلس شكرا ايضا
لضيف
من رام الله الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عبد
المجيد سويلا بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نصل
الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء